Kelly is in Boise Idaho hi Kelly how are
you I'm good how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up in your world
well what's up in my world is I've been
more or less mostly more following your
Total Money Makeover for the past 10
years my wife has never been really
completely on board although she agrees
with it and about six and a half years
ago she became disabled which allowed me
to clean up our debt and other than my
mortgage I am debt free which is nice
and but ten weeks ago she had a stroke
and so forgive me if I get a little
emotional but so she's not doing all
that well but yet she's had long story
short she's now an assistant Libby and I
did not have any long-term care
insurance and I have been able to
through my employer 401k plan I have you
know amassed about one and a half
million dollars but I don't know what to
do with it at this point I don't know
where to go how old are you sexy how old
is she
60 so you guys been married Pete 40-plus
years Wow
well the good news is you've done a
great job with your money well done sir
congratulations
what is your homework you about a little
over 500 what do you I want it
just a little under 100 all right and
you have one and a half million in your
401k in your sixty years old
yes and I just rolled that over because
I'm 60 I rolled that over with one of
your smart better crawlers into an IRA
what's our the majority assisted living
costing and it's about four now because
it's fairly new it's about thirty seven
hundred dollars a pop so about fifty
fifty grand it's gonna be about fifty
grand of your average Ike yeah yeah okay
um well and are you working yes then
what do you make what's your income 120
good for you okay
all right well you don't have a
financial problem you just got a heart
break your your finances are in great
shape I mean I mean you can use the 401
K without penalty you'll just pay some
taxes on it to do whatever you need to
do yeah and that's kind of what I plan
but I just don't know I don't know where
to try to play down the mortgage or work
extra or
now I think I think what I would do is I
take enough of the 401k and pay off the
mortgage this week so that means your
that means you're gonna pull pull about
140 out probably because you got taxes
on it as well and then and then you
don't have a mortgage and you make 120
thousand a year and if you can't cash
flow her care out of your income with no
house payment which you probably can
actually but if you can't then you can
pull down on that 401 K just a little
bit as you need to
because it's going to be sitting there
growing I mean you're 60 years old when
it's 70 you you got a million you said
you had a meeting five yeah okay and we
just reduced it to a million 350 and so
it will be 2.7 million when you're 70 if
it's invested what yeah okay my my
career requires me to retire at 65 on
but if you don't have anything to the
401k 1 million 350 will double about
every seven years okay so by the time
you're 67 to 70 somewhere in there
you're gonna be bumping up around 3
million dollars minus whatever a little
bit you have to pull off for her care
but I don't think you're gonna have to I
think with no house payment you probably
can just about cash flow that assisted
living I don't know what else you're
spending money on right now but the if
you don't if you don't when it's okay if
you pulled the whole 50 out of there
it still doesn't mess up your retirement
okay let me think about if you pull down
50k for five years that's 250,000 you're
still over a million dollars sitting
there with a paid for house and making
120 say you're in great shape your
finances you do not have a problem at
all because you've done such a good job
to this point what a great provider
you've been and you've done a good job
you're a good husband you're good man
and you're an economic hero you did a
great job did you inherit any of this
million no no this is just 401k since I
was 30 or 20 20 28 actually and just
putting a bunch in and my financial
adviser said keep putting in the 6% of
their matching currently is that a good
idea yeah yeah okay
yeah I definitely get that match let's
keep loading that puppy up but let's
take enough out to pay off the house and
take enough out and if you can't
cashflow her care you take a little bit
out but don't you don't need to take
much out don't use her care as an excuse
to drain it down but that's not your
nature your nature's a saver not a
spender anyway yeah but you've you've
done such a good job you're going to be
in fine shape and her care is taking
care of you you've done a good job thank
you proud of you well done sir thank you
for calling in it's not honor to speak
with you
so if you're 28 and you're listening to
that call wake up and don't tell me I
want to live life now while I can that
man just took care of his wife of 40
years why because he systematically
invested and didn't spend everything he
makes like he's in Congress because he
was a grown up and now he's caring for
his wife did you hear him he's a hero
that's a man right there that's not a
little boy walking around a man's body
whining about how his life sucks he took
care of business if that doesn't inspire
you to get up off your butt
nothing does this is the Dave Ramsey
show